JASON DALY: So I am Jason Daly.
I am a software engineer
with Google Fiber.
And I'm going to
talk to you today
about a few points of interest.
We're going to talk about how
we created a TV and DVR user
interface with HTML5,
CSS3, and Dart.
This is running on embedded
hardware, which might
be interesting to some people.
MIPS and ARM devices,
specifically.
And we're also going
to talk about how
I use some Dart VM-based
services running
on these boxes, interacting
with native code
to handle some of the stuff
that the browser can't do,
dealing with sockets and
Native Dart extensions.
So some of you might be
interested in that as well.
So about Google Fiber.
A lot of you probably
already know.
But I'll cover it anyway.
Google Fiber is Google's
fiber-to-the-home internet
service.
We offer customers
up to one gigabit
per second symmetric bandwidth.
So upstream and
downstream, one gigabit.
We also have a TV package
available with it--
about 500 channels or so.
High definition.
Fat, fat bit streams.
It really looks good.
We're really proud of it.
Currently, fiber is deployed
in Kansas City, Provo, Utah,
and Austin, with additional
cities coming soon.
I do not know when your
city or neighborhood
will get Google Fiber.
I'm sorry.
I cannot answer that.
Those are very
complex questions,
way above my pay grade.
I'm just a software engineer.
So I can't answer that question.
I'm sorry.
So at Fiber we
use several pieces
of custom hardware
for the TV service.
So the storage box, which has
a 2 terabyte hard drive in it,
and recent versions
of the software
it combines with
the network box.
We call it the Network+ Box.
There's one of
these per household.
So all your video
goes on to one box.
And then you can have
several TV boxes.
So one TV box per TV,
up to six per household.
That's a recent
expansion from four.
Lot of people in Kansas City are
happy about that, because they
have big houses there.
And we've also got
the network box
in the original hardware,
and the fiber jack.
Which none of those
have Dart codes,
So that's probably the last
time we'll hear about those.
Sorry for the bad
programmer art.
Here is the best I could
do for the picture.
The pretty orange
fiber cable comes
in from outside of your
house into the fiber jack.
From there it's ethernet
to the network box.
Ethernet usually
to the storage box.
And either ethernet,
or we can run over
coax lines using the
Mocha protocol, which
makes it a lot easier to
install in houses that
don't have ethernet built in.
And then for the TV box,
get a nice HDMI cable,
or whatever, to your TV.
We had a previous
UI and DVR system.
It works well.
It's serving thousands
of customers as we speak.
But it's got several things
that are not done-- right
is a very objective thing.
But it's not done the way that
Google usually does things.
For example, lots of heavy
work is done redundantly
on these little limited
embedded devices.
The electronic program
guide specifically
is a huge piece of
data when you consider
the size of the device
we're talking about.
That's hundreds of channels
times two weeks of time.
There's lots of data other
than just the name of the show
and what time it's on in there.
There's lots of metadata
that goes with it.
And we distribute that
to each and every storage
box in the fleet.
And that's probably not
the best way to do it.
Also, there are some
very complex tasks that
get done on the storage box.
DVR scheduling, which is
where when the user sets up
a recording rule, say I want
to record "Law and Order."
Show me every single
episode of "Law and Order"
that you can find.
A lot of computation
has to be done.
Well, when's "Law and Order" on?
Have I already recorded this
episode of "Law and Order"?
Do I have enough
tuners to record
this episode of "Law and
Order," with everything else
I'm recording?
And that's a very
complex problem.
And we do it on a little MIPS
processor, ARM processor.
Also, Search.
When you want to search for a
program, that's a complex task.
Dealing with I've
typed in three letters.
What matches that,
that kind of thing.
And that's all being done,
again, on the storage box.
Mostly this is
implemented in Java,
which means we require
a third-party JVM
license to run on each device.
And the JVM we're using
is not a Google JVM.
It's not something we control.
So whenever it
breaks-- and it does--
we have to deal with external
vendors to help us fix it.
On the other hand, the
previous UI and DVR system
does have some
native code that's
been tuned specifically
for our hardware,
for performance-critical tasks.
And a lot of that we can reuse.
So that's good.
For a new solution, we
wanted to do several things.
We wanted to move most of this
heavy lifting to the Cloud.
So the big data and
the big computation
moves into the Cloud.
Also, we wanted to move some of
the user's data to the Cloud.
Specifically, their preferences
and their settings, and the DVR
recording rules.
So that when one of
their boxes goes down
and we have to replace
it, they don't have
to go set up everything again.
At this point, recorded video
is staying on the hard drive,
mainly because of
licensing reasons.
We can't move that to the Cloud.
This has advantages, obviously.
The large data sets, such
as the program guide,
can be queried instead of
copied all the way down
to every single
device in the fleet.
Whenever somebody hits
Guide on the remote,
it just asks the data center.
And the relevant piece
of data comes down
for say, seven
channels in 90 minutes,
as opposed to 500
channels in two weeks.
Also, the complex tasks such
as scheduling and search
can be done by a data center,
as opposed to a TV box
with limited capabilities.
And again, user data is
not lost if a box breaks.
The settings and the
recording rules are safe.
The recorded videos is lost.
But as soon as you
get the new box,
it'll start recording
all your stuff again.
We still need the UI that
runs on the TV box, though.
So we can't do
everything in the Cloud.
For our goals for
this were, we wanted
it to be at least as
responsive as the existing UI.
We didn't want to go backwards
in terms of performance.
We don't want to rely
on third-party code
as much as we can.
We want to do as much
as we can in-house,
because we can fix things
in-house really easily.
And we wanted this to
be easy to develop,
easy to maintain,
and easy to deploy.
So the decisions we made
was an HTML5 CSS-based UI
running inside Chromium.
And the front end UI
code written in Dart.
Why did we pick Dart?
Well, this is the laundry list
you've heard over and over
again this couple of days.
Dart looks and feels like
a lot of other languages
that people already know.
Most of us on the team,
we're not front end engineers
from background.
A lot of us came up
from C++ or Java.
And Dart looked a lot like
the stuff we already knew.
And we liked a lot of
the features in Dart,
too-- the strict type
checking when you want it,
and the libraries and imports.
It's going to be a
big, big project.
So we wanted to be able to
package up code modually
and reuse it.
Which yes, you can do
that in JavaScript.
But Dart makes a lot prettier
and a lot nicer to deal with.
Also, Dart still has the
dynamic and asynchronous
features that web apps need.
So the dynamic types,
you don't need types
if you don't want them.
And the futures and streams.
We're not using async/await yet.
This happened two years ago.
So we didn't have
that available yet.
We're looking
forward to using it.
But at the moment, if it's
not broke, don't fix it.
We're following that paradigm.
And also, Dart is not limited to
just the browser and web apps.
We'll talk a little bit
more about that later.
But we like that going
from the beginning.
So, using HTML, CSS, and Dart.
We had a lot of
wins in development.
Everybody's talked about how
great the Dart tools are.
Dart's really easy to pick
up compared to JavaScript,
if you're already a
programmer and you haven't
worked with JavaScript already.
We really like Dartium, because
the prototyping is just bam.
It's done.
You write the code and it runs.
You make a change, it runs.
You don't need to recompile.
You just refresh.
And with CSS and HTML, you don't
even need to refresh sometimes.
You just change it
in the debugger.
And bam, there it is.
And UX designers
really like that.
Can you make that red?
Make that a little bit bigger
and move it down five pixels?
Sure.
OK.
Good.
That was really a
nice experience.
For deployment, as opposed to
packaging up a big firmware
image and sending it down
to every box in the fleet,
now we can just say hey, go to
this URL instead of that one.
And now we've got
new UI deployed.
That's really cool.
That's really, really cool.
And also, the server side
software in the Cloud
can be updated.
We don't need to deploy
an image for that, either.
So when the back end needs
to change, that just happens.
And the customers don't
even know the difference,
except that stuff works better.
We did have some challenges
with this, though.
Most of the packages and
libraries and everything
out there for doing
web development
assume you have a mouse
and a pointing device.
We have a remote control.
We have up, down,
left, right, and OK.
So we didn't really
find any widget
or development
libraries, frameworks,
anything like that that
could really work for us.
So we had to develop
our own widgets.
Custom widgets, navigation
system, and all that.
It wasn't terribly
difficult. But it was
a challenge we had overcome.
Again, we have a limited
CPU, limited GPU,
and limited memory.
So we have a lot of effort
went into managing streams
and DOM elements efficiently.
We don't create divs
and throw them away.
We try to reuse them as much as
we can so there's less garbage
collection and everything.
Also, for the big, big
data sets like our video
on demand library, we don't
request everything at once.
We get pages at a time.
We work with the back team to
give us small chunks of data
that we can handle easily.
Also, there's the challenge of
interfacing with the hardware.
This is an embedded CPU.
It can't do software
video decoding.
There's dedicated
hardware for that.
Also, dealing with
digital rights management,
which we have to do.
No content provider
will talk to us
if we didn't have
some kind of way
of protecting their content.
So we had to deal with that.
Largely, this was
accomplished outside of Dart
with native code.
So we have a custom build of
Chromium with a custom video
tag that we can move around
the screen that talks
straight to the decoders.
And some of the
existing native software
that was working
with the old system.
We refactored parts of that and
moved some of it into Chromium.
Some of it stayed
on the storage box.
And so that's how we
dealt with getting
the video actually decoded so
you could actually watch TV.
Here's some screenshots.
This is our program guide.
This particular screen is using
mostly using Canvas right now.
We're looking into a
WebGL version of it
to make it animate a
little bit quicker.
But other than that,
it words pretty well.
This is the on-demand
library I was talking about.
So here's one page with
10 different shows on it.
You can see some of
them bleeding off
to the side to let you know
there's more content if you
just arrow over.
It goes over there, fetches
the next page, and moves on.
Some detailed info.
So this is an episode
of how it's made.
All that data comes
from the guide.
And this is the DVR.
So this is what's going
to be recorded coming up.
Now, that's great for the UI.
It worked really well.
We were moving forward.
We were really happy.
We like Dart.
But the browser can't do
everything, it turns out.
We need to be able to
record video to disk.
We need to be able to play
back video from the disk.
We need to be able to
delete stuff from the disk.
We also have some
third-party applications.
Like we have a Netflix
client on our TV box.
We need to launch that.
None of that is something
that the browser can do.
So some of this week we
handled with native code.
Again, recycling some of the
code we had in the old system
that was already tuned to run
really well on our hardware.
So the recording
and the streaming
is how we dealt with that.
And the other tasks that
weren't so performance-critical,
but were still
very necessary, we
decided to write some
services running into Dart VM
to do that.
Again, why Dart?
Well, it makes sense.
We already have a
bunch of Dart code.
Let's write some more
Dart code instead
of having to switch languages
back and forth all the time.
Dart works just great
outside of the browser.
There's no limitations
on that at all.
Or very little, at least.
And we also could do a lot
of code reuse this way.
So things like the code that
interfaces with the back end.
We could use that on
both inside the browser
and outside the
browser and the VMs.
Some of the logging we do too.
So when something breaks,
we get a flag immediately.
That needs to be
done consistently,
so we recycle the loggers.
And other things like that.
it made sense to be able
to reuse all this code.
So we decided to
pick Dart again.
The DVR service.
This one runs in the Dart
VM on the storage box.
This service handles
live TV tuning.
It handles recording,
playback, and file management.
The recording instructions,
which come from the Cloud,
are executed by this service.
Basically, when you
set up recording rules
in the TV client, that sets up
recording rules in the Cloud.
The Cloud does a bunch
of processing on that
and turns those into specific
instructions, which say,
record channel X
from time Y to time
Z. Those come down to this
service on the storage box.
And the storage box
handles those instructions,
recording that video.
Also, when the disk
fills up, we need
to be able to delete
files to free up space.
So files are deleted, again,
according to instructions
from the back end.
Because that's a complex task,
figuring out which file should
I delete before
what other files.
Also, this service
interacts with native code
to control the actual
capture and streaming.
So on our storage box
we have eight tuners,
which are not really tuners.
They're basically just threads
that write to the disk.
So we could can record up
to eight things at once.
And also, we can stream
six things at once,
because we have six TV boxes.
So you can be
recording eight things,
and streaming six
of them to your TV.
Or six other things, if
you have stuff recorded.
That's something that
really screams native code.
That's not something
we want to run in a VM.
We want to run that as close
to the metal as possible.
So we recycled the
service that was
used in the original software.
We basically didn't
even change it.
We just copied it onto the
disk and started talking to it.
Just like the old code did.
Most of that is done
with TCP sockets.
Also, the service
writes out some metadata
files while it's recording.
And we needed to be able
to read those to do things
like determine how
long a file is--
not in bytes, but in seconds.
How many seconds is
this file of video?
And to do that, we wrote a
native extension to talk to one
of that service's libraries.
So we just write a real simple
Dart wrapper around that.
We can call methods
into that library.
And we can figure out
things like how long is it,
or how far in is 50
seconds, so we can seek
to a certain point in the file.
We also interact
with the TV itself.
The TV UI, that part
that's running in Dart.
We use a WebSocket for that.
So when the user wants
to change the channel,
hits channel up on the remote.
That sends a command
to the DVR service
that says, stop recording
what you're doing.
Start recording
this new channel.
And then start
streaming it to me.
And then additional
native extension
we had to write to interact
with the operating systems.
Mainly because Dart doesn't
have a version of STAT DFS,
if you're familiar
with that, to look
at how big file systems are.
How big they are, how much is
used, and how much is free.
And that's something
we needed to know
to be able to know when
the disk is filling up,
and to ask what files
we should delete.
So that was a real
simple wrapper.
That took like a day to write.
Not even a day, really.
Like an hour.
It was really,
really super simple.
Also, we've got
a TV box service.
This is outside
the browser again.
And this is handling
things, again,
that the browser can't do.
Specifically, we need to be
able to switch applications.
We need to be able to start
Google Fiber TV when we want.
We need to be able to
shut it down, switch
to a third-party app,
say Netflix or YouTube.
And we also need to be
able to turn it off.
And once we turn it
off, we need to be
able to turn it back on again.
So we needed some additional
smarts outside of the browser
to be able to do all that.
We have a mobile client.
And the mobile client, in
order to control the TV,
needs to be able to
talk to a service that
can interface with the browser.
So again, we have
another WebSocket open
for that inside of this service,
to let mobile clients connect
and be able to control TVs.
We also do things like-- say you
switch from 16 by 9 to 4 by 3.
That's not something we
can do inside the browser,
because that's dealing
with video hardware
itself, and not just the video.
So we needed to be able
to switch video streams,
switch audio streams.
Also, closed caption
data comes down
that doesn't come through
the video tag we have.
Instead, it's routed outside
through another socket.
And also DRM.
Fetching DRM keys from
our secure service
to be able to install
the keys on the device,
and be able to decrypt
video properly.
That was done by the service.
So this new TV UI and DVR system
we launched in mid-January
this year to new customers.
We don't have a
migration path just yet.
But it's coming up really soon.
And so far customers are
pretty happy with it.
It's pretty seamless going
from one system to the other.
It's hard to tell
the difference,
unless you're really
familiar with it.
And we're happy about that.
In conclusion, we
really like Dart.
Developing this stuff
was fun because of Dart
and all the tools we have.
We really enjoyed it.
Dar is versatile.
It's powerful.
It's fun to develop with.
It also works just fine
on embedded hardware.
We might have had two or
three really minor issues that
were handled really
quickly by the VM team
during this process.
So we couldn't be happier with
how well it works on our boxes.
And with that, are
there any questions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SPEAKER 2: I'll be
question monkey.
Would you like a mic?
You like how I just materialize
on stage in time for this?
AUDIENCE: Going
forward, are you going
to focus on either ARM or MIPS?
Or are you using
both on purpose?
JASON DALY: We do have new
revisions of the customer
equipment coming up.
I can't really talk about
which way we're going.
AUDIENCE: OK.
JASON DALY: A lot of it is
undetermined at this point.
And even if it was determined,
that's not something
that we talk about publicly.
SPEAKER 2: Anyone else?
Back here.
AUDIENCE: How did you deal
with managing shared objects
and shipping them in packages
for the shared wrapper objects,
the native wrappers.
JASON DALY: Oh, for
the native extensions?
I might have been a
little bit misleading.
The browser in the
back end code we
don't have to ship new
firmware images for.
For the VM services
that run on the boxes,
those are part of the firmware.
So it just packs up right
along with the firmware.
SPEAKER 2: Any more?
Probably do one more question.
Or not.
OK.
Thank you so much.
JASON DALY: Thanks a lot.
[APPLAUSE]